he was the wartime prime minister who
led Britain to victory over Nazi Germany
Sir Winston Churchill was once voted the
greatest Briton of all time but some
view him very differently Winston
Churchill hero or villain Tony panting
villain tony pandey in the Rhondda
Valley in South Wales is a former mining
town in 1910 the miners went on strike
after riots broke out Churchill then
Home Secretary sent in soldiers the
clashes that followed left hundreds
injured and one miner dead in Tony
Pandey they haven't forgotten Winston
Churchill hero or villain
deep villain but I think he was a bit of
both he was the hero anywhere as a lone
English hero
we're alone wasn't the only mind that
remains in the valley is now a museum a
reminder of what happened here
Churchill's role in the - strikes
remains a source of great resentment
towards him here in South Wales but it
wasn't the only controversy of his
career he was the war secretary who
deployed the Black and Tans in Ireland
the force became known for violence and
brutality
Churchill's treatment of people within
the British Empire has led to
accusations of racism he was criticised
for his lack of action when a serious
famine in Bengal left 3 million people
dead the genocide or numbers of people
who were killed and died in places like
Kenya and India under the British
cláudio administration happen under
Winston Churchill's watch and so it
wasn't just his words that were
violently ray stood up they were
but politicians have defended Churchill
a spokesperson for the Prime Minister
said his strong leadership through
Britain's darkest hour help protect
values of peace and freedom
you can't write history without him in
the middle of it because he is that
right there at the center of British
history and a hero to great many Britons
Churchill's many achievements are beyond
doubt but despite his wartime legacy
whether he was a hero or villain depends
on who you ask Becky Johnson skying New
South Wales